LOOK AT THE LATEST QUINNIPIAC
POLL.
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING IN THE
SEWERS.
SENATOR TED CRUZ, LET'S START
WITH MERRICK GARLAND, REALLY?
PARENTS HAVE NO RIGHT TO HAVE A
SAY ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION.
WHY DON'T WE JUST HAND AT THE
KIDS OVER TO THE GOVERNMENT, LET
THEM RAISE THEM BECAUSE THAT
APPARENTLY IS WHAT THEY WANT.
>> IN ANY CRISIS SOMEONE'S
CHARACTER IS REVEALED AND COVID
HAS SHOWED THE CHARACTER OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE AUTHORITARIAN.
THERE IS NO DECISION ABOUT YOUR
LIFE THEY WILL NOT TRY TO
CONTROL WHETHER THAT IS A
VACCINE MANDATE REGARDLESS OF
HER CHOICES, GAVIN NEWSOM TRYING
TO ORDER EVERY SCHOOL KID IN
CALIFORNIA TO GET A VACCINE,
REGARDLESS OF THEIR PARENTS'S
WISHES, OR WHETHER IT COMES TO
SILENCING FREE SPEECH.
YOU KNOW, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
MEMORANDUM THIS WEEK, DIRECTED
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO GO AFTER PARENTS WHO
ARE GOING TO SCHOOL BOARDS, WHO
ARE EXPRESSING DISMAY THAT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, THE TOXIC
STEW OF LIES THAT DIVIDES US
BASED ON RACE, THAT TEACHES KIDS
THAT AMERICA IS INHERENTLY
RACIST AND ALL WHITE PEOPLE ARE
RACIST, THAT SEEKS TO TURN US
INTO HATING EACH OTHER ON RACIAL
LINES, PARENTS ARE
UNDERSTANDABLY UPSET ABOUT THAT
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TOLD
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THAT
THOSE PARENTS OF SCHOOL BOARDS
SHOULD BE TREATED AS THREATS AND
AS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS AND
DIRECTING THE FBI TO USE ALL THE
FORCES OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AGAINST THEM.
TODAY, AND YOU PUT UP JUST A
MINUTE AGO THE HEAD OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DIVISION AND DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, I ASKED HER, DO YOU
REALLY THINK PARENTS OF SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE DOMESTIC TERRORISTS?
SHE REFUSED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
I SAID, DID THEY HAVE ANY CIVIL